كنت أه أقوم بإخلاء شمال غزة
الذي طلبت إسرائيل من الناس مراراً وتكراراً
إخلاءه وكنت ذاهباً إلى
ولا إلى الجزء الجنوبي من
قطاع غزة على أمل الوصول إلى معبر
رفح الحدودي مع زوجتي
وأطفالي الثلاثة ولكن  عندما وصلت إلى
الحاجز الذي أقامته إسرائيل أه في
شارع صلاح الدين والذي كان يسمى
ممرا آمنا للفلسطينيين الذين يحاولون
الإخلاء أه إلى الجزء الجنوبي تم
استدعائي بالوصف من قبل
جندي إسرائيلي كان على بعد حوالي أه 150 متر
من الخط الذي كان فيه  هل كان يطلب مني أن
أنزل ابني وأن أسقط
حقائب الظهر الخاصة بي أه وأن انضم إلى صف
الأشخاص الآخرين الذين تم
الاتصال بهم والذين اتصلنا بهم قبل أن يتم مناداتي بالاسم لاحقًا
ثم تم نقلي إلى منطقة أخرى
مع جنديين إسرائيليين  صوبوا
بنادقهم نحوي وكانوا يطلبون مني
خلع ملابسي، فخلعت كل ملابسي
وسترتي وسروالي، وبعد ذلك لم أرتدي سوى
شورت الملاكم الخاص بي، وكان
الجنديان ينظران إلى بعضهما البعض
ويتحدثان بالعبرية، ثم قام  قال كمل
اخلع السروال البوكسر
وبعدين نظرت للشخص التاني اللي جنبي
الفلسطيني اللي جنبي
وهو كمان اه معتقل معي
وتفاجأنا بأنهم يطلبون منا
تجريدنا من كل ملابسنا لذلك كان علينا
لا شيء أفعله سوى خلع سراويلنا الداخلية
ثم عندما كنت عاريًا
لأول مرة في حياتي أه أمام
الغرباء طلب مني أن
أستدير ففعلت ما طلبوه
ثم تم تقييد يدي وكنت أه
معصوب العينين ومن ثم تم نقلي إلى
منطقة قريبة جداً وتم التحقيق معي
وقدمت نفسي باللغة الإنجليزية وطلبت
منه أه أه ليسمع ما
أقوله كنت عائداً للتو إلى
غزة أه قبل 7 أكتوبر بـ 10 أيام
وأخبرته بكل شيء عني
ثم رأيت أنه قال أنت ناشط في حماس
وأوقفنا زوجتك وأطفالك الثلاثة
لذلك كان يهددني مع
عائلتي، أوقفوا زوجتي
وثلاثة أطفال عند نقطة التفتيش التالية
فقلت له هل تفعل ذلك؟  هل لديك أي دليل أي
دليل على أنني ناشط في حماس أو
صورة أو فيديو أو صورة قمر صناعي
تظهر أي شيء ثم صفعني
على وجهي وقال أعطني
دليلاً وكنت أتساءل أعني
كيف يمكنني أن أعطيك  يوافق على
أنني لست حمص ومن ثم أخذوني
وتعرضت للضرب وكنت أه أه معاملة سيئة بعنف
مع شباب آخرين
مثلي وكان هناك شخص بجانبي
كان يبكي ويقول من فضلك أريد
العودة إلى زوجتي الحامل  وابنتي
الصغيرة
اه بحيث كان ذلك جزء من
أه يومي خلال الأول أه
اليوم الأول وبعد ذلك وجدت نفسي
في معتقل إسرائيلي أه مركز أه
فيما بعد عرفت أنها بي أو ب
أم وبعد ذلك أنا  تم استجوابي من قبل
كابتن إسرائيلي أخبرته عن نفسي
بكل شيء وأه لم يكن يومًا صعبًا
بالنسبة لي ولكن بالنسبة للآخرين كان يومًا صعبًا وبعد ذلك قال
حسنًا، سنفعل،
سنتحقق من المعلومات التي قدمتها
لنا وبعد ذلك اثنان  بعد ساعات
قال جندي إسرائيلي نحن آسفون على
الخطأ الذي ارتكبته، أنت عائد إلى المنزل ثم
قلت هل أنت جاد في ذلك،
أعني أنني سأكون مع عائلتي
وأطفالي، فقال أنا جاد و
ثم قلت لنفسي فيما بعد إنني أقصد
كم من الأخطاء ارتكبها الجيش الإسرائيلي
ضد الفلسطينيين الآخرين